hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in part three of his discourse on method
rene descartes is going to lay out
something that has come to be called the
provisional morality on my apologies
young in his French and another way of
you could translate this is a temporary
ethics and ethics that you have in place
until you can build something on on more
solid foundations now why does he do
this he thinks that it's important as he
says he again using his building
metaphor that that just like those
people who are rebuilding a house before
built beginning to rebuild the house you
don't just demolish it and make
provision for materials you also have to
have someplace to live for the time
being and that's what this provisional
morality is providing him with and he
talks in terms of Maxim's he says that
there's three or four it actually turns
out to be three main Maxim's by which he
can he can conduct himself so what is a
maxim a maxim is a rule that you give to
yourself or give to other people it can
usually be expressed in one or two lines
and it tells you what to do or what
things are in this case these are all
doing Maxim's this is how I ought to
behave so they're really three sets of
Maxim's he doesn't condense them down to
a single line for each of them and he
gives actually quite a bit of
explanation that we're going to look at
so what is the first of these Maxim's he
says the first is to obey the laws and
customs of my country and then he adds
to that to adhere to the religion in
which God by His grace had me instructed
by it from my childhood and then he adds
another third part to it to govern
myself in everything else according to
the most moderate and least extreme
opinions being those commonly received
among the wisest of those those with
whom I should have to live so this is
actually quite a lot
that's that's almost a short paragraph
rather than a one-line sentence right
and notice that he's dividing things
into three classes there's anything that
has to do with laws and customs so
there's a social level then there is
religion alright another level also
applying to to the group but applying to
individual actions and beliefs and
attitudes and then there is everything
else so let's look at each of these he
says I'm going to obey the laws and
customs of my country why why not the
laws and customs of the Persians or the
Chinese he says well I'm living here so
it actually makes sense for me to follow
these rules to keep myself out of
trouble he says there might be just as
many wise people among among these other
people but I should follow those with
whom I have to live what about religion
he doesn't actually tell you that much
about this and if we look at de cartes
own behavior and his expressed
sentiments another place this is
probably just sort of a concession to
the piety of the time he's not going to
do anything that he thinks will
scandalize all the other people he's
going if he goes to a church for example
he'll get up and say the right thing at
the right time but he's you know going
to more or less leave that alone what he
devotes the most discussion to is
following reasonable opinions so what
does he tell us he says here we go I
have to follow the reasonable opinions
of those who are the wisest among
ourselves because I have to regulate my
conduct by that of the people among whom
I'm going to live and for me to know
what their opinions really were had to
take note of what they did rather than
said and he says I chose only the most
moderate among many opinions which were
equally widely received as much as
because these are easiest to practice
and likely to be the best so he's he's
saying excesses
are usually bad that seems to be fairly
Aristotelian you know the notion of the
the virtuous mean or middle and it at
least keep him out of trouble
with other people and he says in
particular I placed in the category of
excesses all personal commitments by
which one relinquishes some of one's
freedom now he doesn't say I'm never
gonna make a promise to anybody as a
matter of fact he considers that there
and says this is needed for people who
otherwise are ear resolute but I'm not
going to commit myself too much in any
particular say ideology or cause or
commitment of that sort so what is this
going to guarantee for him it's going to
allow him a kind of freedom to maneuver
within a society that he has to share
with other people
so that's the first maxim the second
maxim more interesting be as firm and
resolute in actions as possible right
following out he says even doubtful
opinions now you might say well why
would Descartes want to follow opinions
that are doubtful and he gives you a
metaphor here he says I imitate
travelers who finding themselves lost in
a forest they don't want to just wander
around in circles right because then
you're consuming your time and energy
and it's gonna become nightfall and you
don't actually make it out of the forest
as a matter of fact if you find yourself
isn't the same place again after
circling around you know that you're in
trouble right so head on a straight line
it doesn't really matter he's saying if
you know that that's the right way to go
you you go straight you're gonna hit
something sooner or later you're going
to arrive somewhere that you can
actually use maybe it'll be a river
maybe it'll be a road maybe it'll be net
you know nest of bears or something like
that but you're bound to hit something
so he says you should walk as straight
as possible in one direction not alter
course for weak reasons even if it might
only have been chance which led this
person to settle on the direction that
they chose
he says what's the result of this they
don't end up precisely where they want
to be but they are going to reach
somewhere where they're more likely to
be better off than in the middle of a
forest so what is the forest here it's
this state of doubt that Descartes is in
worried about the fact that he's got
this great education that doesn't seem
to provide him yet with any certainty
about what's real what's true and how he
ought to live so he's going to just
stick with something and he's gonna be
firm and resolute about it he's going to
follow it out even if there are doubts
about those sorts of things so he says
we must often act in life without a
delay it's a very certain truth that
when it's not in our power to determine
determine what the truest opinions are
we should follow those most likely to be
true and even though we see no more
probability in some rather than others
we have to pick one of them we have to
commit ourselves one way and then follow
that out and and if you do that you're
actually acting in an experimental
manner and maybe you'll find something
out along the way that that's quite
useful
his third Maxim which he's deriving most
experts thinking in large part from
stoic ethics is to master himself rather
than fortune that's the first part of it
to change his desires rather than
attempting to change the world and to
realize that only certain things are
within our power namely our thoughts so
we need to talk about each of these in
turn
all right he says that I need to master
myself rather than fortune what is
fortune fortune is this you know chance
events that happen within the world you
know getting a promotion at work getting
fired that's a matter of fortune other
people other factors control that and
you know if you're going to try to
master fortune you're if you
if you are successful for a certain
amount of time there's this you know
metaphor of the wheel it's always going
to turn and you're probably going to
lose out on whatever it is that you got
so you know for the moment you're good
looking well all it takes is an accident
or aging or something else to come along
and change that you're rich right now
well all that money can go away that
property can be destroyed in an
earthquake or the government can come in
and take it or you know locusts can come
in and eat your fields and we can go on
and on and on you've got a you know
wonderful spouse here she can die right
you've got great children maybe they'll
they'll go crazy and and act in terrible
ways that that brings shame upon your
family so so master yourself rather than
trying to master fortune that means that
you actually have to spend some time
trying to figure out well who are you
what kind of thing are you how do you
work what would it mean to be a better
you and that's where we get to the
second part changing desires rather than
trying to change the order of the world
so he tells us this our will is
naturally inclined to desire only those
things which our intellect represents to
it as possible in some way so if we if
we apply a certain kind of mental
discipline to ourselves we can bring
ourselves to desire less and certainly
not to desire the things that are going
to get us in trouble what is in our
control our thoughts according to
Descartes now this is this covers a wide
range because we have a tendency to
think that thoughts are just you know
like cognitive propositions or something
along those lines or imaginations that
indeed is part of the range of thought
willing is a kind of thinking for
Descartes sensing is a kind of thinking
your emotions are actually types of
thoughts for a Descartes now he's not
saying that you actually do have total
control over your emotional reactions or
the sense perceptions that you're having
but we do have control over you know
whether we imagine those things
the ways in which we think about things
how we conduct our thoughts whether we
think about things that we ought to
think about or we just put off thinking
about them all of those are more or less
within our power so he goes on and he
says if we represent by our intellect
something as possible it's certain that
if we consider all external goods as
being equally beyond their power we're
not going to feel regret at failing to
obtain those which seem to be our
birthright when deprived of them through
no fault of our own when fortune hits us
we're not going to be so upset because
we say well you know easy come easy go
those are external things I don't
actually have control over them it was
silly for me to desire them that or to
desire to hold on to them forever as if
that's actually possible if I represent
things to myself accurately then
according to Descartes I'm not going to
be beset by those types of desires and
he says now of course this requires you
know habit and as he calls it here long
practice and reiterated periods of
meditation to make oneself used to
seeing things from that angle
it's not something that you think boom
and now you realize it and everything
falls into place it may feel like that
when you first hear it but you have to
keep thinking this you have to keep
reminding yourself of that and that is
something that Descartes probably did in
fact take from the Stoics now I had
mentioned at the beginning that
Descartes said well there's three or
maybe four different Maxim's that I I
need to look at and he says in
conclusion he says finally as a
conclusion to this moral code that's
more how I decided to review the various
occupations men have in this life this
is not really a maxim this is kind of a
summary this is what the following these
things is going to allow him to do and a
little bit later in that paragraph he
will talk about the three foregoing
Maxim's so what is he actually trying to
do with this force fourth thing that
could be framed as a maxim what are
occupations so we think of occupation
just in terms of work like I'm gonna go
apply for an office job or I'll work in
a restaurant or I'll be a nurse and take
care of people at home or in the
hospital well occupation is really how
you run your life and work is a major
part of that so Descartes says you know
I wanted to review the different
occupations that people have in this
life in order to select the best one
without passing judgment on others I
came to the view he says that I eyed a
cart could you know better than to
continue in the one in which I found
myself to devote my life to the
cultivation of my reason and make such
progress as I could a knowledge of the
truth following the method the the
method described in part two that I had
prescribed for myself so you could see
another maxim there I should follow out
this practice of being a working
philosopher philosopher in a very broad
and general sense applying the method
the four rules that I derived earlier
all of those form a sort of coherent way
of living that could in fact be replaced
it won't really be replaced for the most
part but could be replaced if his
investigations revealed something better
for him so that is des cartes
provisional morality
you